müssen wir alle sterben das hier ist
dann kann sie wurde im februar 1875
geboren und starb im august 1997 im
alter von 122 jahren und 164 tagen das
macht die französin offiziell zu der
person mit dem längsten leben in ihrem
langen leben hat sie gesehen wie der
eiffelturm gebaut wurde
sie hat zwei weltkriege miterlebt und
mit 13 jahren hat die stifte an vincent
van gogh verkauft und ihr nach über 100
jahren noch recht negativ in erinnerung
im moment sind nur noch fünf menschen am
leben die im vorletzten jahrhundert
geboren wurden
und das sind alles frauen dass frauen
durchschnittlich älter werden als männer
ist seit längerem bekannt wird aber von
der medizin immer noch nicht komplett
verstanden
zurückgeführt wird es häufig auf den
risikoreicheren lebensstil von männern
männer sind im militär oder in
gefährlichen berufen trinken mehr
alkohol und essen fertig und generell
sind sie auch selber schuld denn männer
begehen statistisch gesehen häufiger
suizid
aber warum müssen wir überhaupt sterben
bei fast allen lebewesen nimmt die
fähigkeit zur selbstregulation mit dem
alterungsprozess ab unsere zellen können
sich nicht mehr neu bilden und so
sterben sie irgendwann einfach ohne
ersetzt zu werden
das ergebnis sind schlaffe haut
muskelschwund und irgendwann
herzstillstand aber gibt es denn keine
möglichkeit das zu verhindern könnten
wir theoretisch unsterblich werden
immerhin haben wir in den letzten 100
jahren erstaunliche fortschritte gemacht
durch bessere medizinische versorgung
und hygiene konnten wir die
durchschnittliche lebenserwartung
innerhalb von circa 200 jahren mehr als
verdoppeln
doch obwohl wir uns in dieser hinsicht
immer weiter verbessern
schließen wir er die typischen
todesursachen aus krankheiten und
verletzungen sind heutzutage viel
seltener die eigentliche todesursache
als früher
was also wenn wir irgendwann nicht mehr
weiterkommen wenn jeder relativ
zuverlässig bis in das alter kommt in
dem sich die zellen nicht mehr
reproduzieren und organe beginnen zu
versagen
im mittelmeer haben forscher vor einiger
zeit die qualle thurid ops ist ricola
entdeckt ab einem bestimmten alter
aktiviert die qualle einzel programm das
sie wieder jungen macht sie altert also
rückwärts benjamin button style
das macht sie so lange bis sie wie ein
kleines baby ist und altert ab dann
wieder normal
solange sie also nicht gepresst wird
kann die quelle quasi nicht sterben
das ist einmalig in der tierwelt doch
leider kommen mit diesen prozess auch
probleme zum beispiel werden auch die
nerven und schlangen zellen in einen
früheren zustand zurückversetzt die
identität der qualle wenn man das so
nennen kann geht dabei auch verloren
also selbst wenn man die genetischen
code auf menschen anwenden könnte was
höchst spekulativ ist dann würde man
regelmäßig und im wahrsten sinne des
wortes ein komplett neuer mensch werden
und man könnte sich nicht an das leben
von früher erinnern
ein aktueller trend in der medizin ist
das ersetzen von kaputten organ durch
künstlich hergestellte organe in einem
anderen video habe ich schon mal darüber
gesprochen
inzwischen kann man fast alles ersetzen
knochen luftröhren blasen nieren
herzklappen ohren augen arme und beine
sowie so wir werden zwei blocks zum teil
mensch und zum anderen teil maschine
doch auch hier stoßen auf ein problem
unser gehirn das was uns ausmacht der
teil in dem unsere persönlichkeit steckt
das können wir nicht einfach gegen ein
neueres modell austauschen
doch unser gehirn alter trotzdem
unaufhaltsam verlieren wir myelin gehirn
schon nennt sich das wenn weiß die
gehirnsubstanz abgebaut wird und
ausläufer von nervenzellen nicht mehr
umhüllt sind wir verlieren an
gehirnleistung aber unser körper ist
doch sowieso nur eine hülle für den
geist könnte man nicht sein gehirn in
einen computer hochladen sowie johnny
depp in trance sendens ich meine dann
ist man unsterblich und könnte sogar
noch seine kapazitäten ausweiten indem
man eine verbindung zum internet
herstellt man könnte immer intelligenter
werden
nehmen wir mal an wissenschaftler
könnten ein menschliches gehirn exakt
simulieren und wüssten auch noch wie man
dein gehirn ausliest und kopiert dann
ist das computerprogramm das dabei
entsteht nicht du es ist etwas
eigenständiges eine kopie von hier
denn es wurde ja gerade kopiert du
bleibst mit deinem bewusstsein immer
noch in deinem kopf während im internet
eine super intelligenz mit deinen
charakterzügen die vor und unsicher
macht wirkliche unsterblichkeit ist das
auch nicht
und am ende müssen wir uns fragen wollen
wir das überhaupt und sterblichkeit was
soll man mit soviel zeit anfangen was
treibt uns an wenn nicht der tod
aber suchen wir noch mal etwas zurück
was ist denn mit uns können wir
zumindest als spezies unsterblich werden
und ewig weiterleben
nun ja seit der entstehung von leben gab
es fünf wirklich große ereignisse bei
denen in relativ kurzer zeit 50 bis 95
prozent aller tierarten ausgestorben
sind
ein meteorit wie der der die dinosaurier
und 75 prozent aller damals lebenden
tierarten tötete könnte jederzeit aus
dem weltall auftauchen
diese dinger sind sehr schwierig zu
erkennen und je nach größe dieses
gesteinsbrocken sind sich
wissenschaftler nicht sicher ob sie das
geschoss rechtzeitig abwenden oder
zerstückeln könnten
gammastrahlen schwarze löcher spätestens
da sterben unserer sonne in drei bis
fünf milliarden jahren wird das ende für
alle tierarten auf der erde bedeuten
wir befinden uns übrigens jetzt gerade
in einem menschen gemachten
massenaussterben die lebensbedingungen
auf unserem blauen planeten sind einfach
so fragil dass schon kleine
veränderungen das ende für viele tier
und pflanzenarten bedeuten können und
wer weiß wir uns versehen könnten die
bedingungen sogar für uns menschen
tödlich sein
das leben auf der erde ist saugefährlich
und es könnte ständig etwas schief gehen
was können wir dagegen tun wie können
wir sicherstellen dass unsere spezies
überlebt die antwort ist leicht wir
müssen multi planeta werden wir müssen
auf andere planeten auswandern
sobald wir eine unabhängige und
lebensfähige gesellschaft auf dem mars
oder auf irgendeinem anderen planeten
haben
sinken die chancen für das aussterben
unserer spezies gewaltig sowie tim erst
gesagt hat wenn du eine datei hast dir
unglaublich wichtig ist dann machst du
dir ein backup auf einer anderen
festplatte und andere planeten sind
unsere festplatte sobald wir das
geschafft haben wenn wir uns erstmal im
sonnensystem und generell im weltraum
ausgebreitet haben
dann kann uns kommen noch etwas stoppen
dann ist unsere spezies quasi
unsterblich
okay und ich möchte jetzt mal ein
kleines experiment starten ich möchte
dass ihr alle in die kommentare schreibt
wie alt ihr gerade seid und was ihr
denkt wie alt ihr werdet ihr unten in
die kommentare gerne auch mit einer
kurzen erklärung bin sehr gespannt was
dabei rauskommt ich bin jetzt 19 und ich
tippe mal dass die wissenschaft ihnen
ein paar jahrzehnten so weit ist dass
ich wenn ich wollte über 100 jahre alt
werden kann
ich sage also mal 110 wenn euch das
video gefallen hat dann abonniert main
kanal und
einen daumen nach oben da und wenn ihr
das erste video noch nicht gesehen habt
haben maschinen einen bewusstsein
dann könnt ihr euch das hier angucken
viel spaß damit und bis bald